we got plenty of time to go over
everything that happened thursday night
and everything that is to come on the
sixth sunday of the 2019 nfl regular
season and you know you're gonna hear
this
pretty much every week i can't believe
it's x week of the season i can't
believe it's that week i can't believe
it's week six i really can't it's flying
by as it always does big cat
stop mike i hate when people do that
even though i did that on my own show
today because the college
i know you don't watch college football
but the college season is already half
over or this week is week seven it goes
14 weeks so i agree i would like to
pause time there's nothing better than
the month of october for sports it is
the best month it's beautiful out it's
great to have football you have ruined
football and we will never recover
as a century
you've you've got to stop this i mean it
was funny like the first two or three
times but you're referring let me just
let me don't filibuster senator let me
let me make my point
you you you are blaming me
for replay review of past interference
as if replay review of past interference
is actually doing a damn thing to the
game we are at the point where the
coaches need to realize you're wasting
your time we saw it again last night
from pat shurmur when the game was out
of hand it was 35 to 14 golden tate was
clearly interfered with the officials
clearly missed it in real time but
there's pat shurmur throwing the red
flag and slowing the game down because
he wants to challenge something that is
not going to be overturned they have
essentially i believe big cat watch this
show they watched you a few weeks ago
talking about the big red button and
they are going to use this device
as the big red button in the event that
there's another ram saints debacle in
the playoffs until then it ain't getting
touched it's not getting used and these
coaches are continuously wasting
timeouts and wasting challenges and
wasting our time and you know what did
you notice how quickly they overturned
it last night it's like they didn't even
look at it it's like what's he doing
he's challenging past interference don't
they know we're not gonna overturn it
upheld go and and so don't blame this on
me they ignore it now it's only there in
the event that there's a true emergency
which is what you wanted not me okay
listen i will agree with you that
at this point if you are a coach burning
a timeout on a pass interference call
that's the only person you can blame is
yourself
i will also say that the nfl is genius
they've done it yet again i've stumbled
upon this thought during the week since
we last saw each other on friday the nfl
put this rule in place so that it could
fail so miserably that they can then
take it away in the office and say see
we listen to our fans we always take
criticism so i'm going to give the nfl
credit for this i want i i will shift
off this for a second the past
interference let's talk about pat
sherman real quick
pat shurmur last night punting the ball
on fourth and two throwing deep on third
and two punting on fourth and two when
you're down 14 points told me everything
i need to know about the rest of the
giant season and about the rest of the
patch shurmur error i'm being serious
mike that was an ouching decision that
told me that pat shurmur is more
concerned about the perception of the
final score in his job than he is about
winning football games
i agree with you completely and i said
that last hour not in those words but
the idea was i don't want it to be 35 to
14. that's the i'll take a 14 point loss
and go home i concede can we just end
the game here that's what that was that
wasn't i'm still alive i'm playing the
percentages i'm gonna keep the ball or
at least try to and you know didn't we
all know that no matter what happened on
that drive by the giants the patriots
were still going to cover i mean we knew
once it went 28 14 it's like oh here it
comes here it comes it looked like they
had no chance to cover and they're going
to cover whether it's a punt whether
it's going forward on fourth and two or
not making it whether it's another
fumble another interception whatever but
you're right if you want to try to win
that game you've got to you you have no
choice but to go for it there
you have no choice to go for it there
and i will
listen the cover was in doubt because i
had the patriots minus 17 and i was
nervous at the end
but pat shurmur how do you when you and
i know the giants aren't good and i know
they're not going to the playoffs but
you're two and four you have a young
quarterback that you're trying to have
reinvigorate the team the locker room
have guys feel like they're buying back
in and you do something like this
it just feels like the wrong message you
send to your team your fans everything
and i and pat shirmer
in a weird way has had this nice coat of
armor with eli manning the last couple
years where he can basically say it's
not me
it's a order from up high i need to put
eli out there eli's not able to win us
games but i'm trying my best to respect
his legacy and all the mumbo jumbo
now pat shurmur this is a situation
where you got to win games and you got
to be aggressive and you have to have
your rookie quarterback continue to buy
into what you're doing so i was really i
was disappointed in that play call and i
was disappointed in the message it sends
and i think other than that the giants
showed a lot more fight than a lot of
people expected their defense which is
31st in the nfl was active and turned
the ball over twice on tom brady
including a you know a strip sack for a
score so i thought there were some
positives you could take away from that
game if you're the new york giants if
you're a giants fan but then you have
pat sherbert do that in the fourth
quarter you say what was the point of
all of this
yeah and he was asked after the game by
reporters why he punted in that
situation his answer was i felt like it
was the right thing to do
no
no yeah you felt like you felt like you
wanted to make sure that you lost by 14
and everyone walked away saying man the
giants really gave the patriots all they
could handle and they got something well
guess what the patriots then went down
and scored and your fourth and two call
looks even dumber
and think about the benefit to a young
quarterback like daniel jones if you go
for it on fourth and two and you convert
it that's just a little boost a little
bump a little something he has when you
go for it on fourth and two in a game
where you have a better chance of
winning right you're building the
confidence of this young quarterback who
has looked good so far and you're
showing in that moment you have no
confidence in him or at least not enough
to risk a headline that is pat's trounce
giants 35 to 14. because it and this
isn't even the people walking away from
the game last night because the people
who watched the game understood what
happened and then it was a closer game
than 35 to 14. this is for the benefit
of all the people flipping through the
newspaper today and they say you know he
wanted him to see 2814 instead of 35 14
or 38 14 or whatever it would have
become and uh he deserves more criticism
for that than anything else we could
criticize him for because that is a
shallow and superficial approach to his
job and i agree with you completely all
he cared about in that moment is getting
out of there with a score that would
look
respectable when people who paid no
attention to the game became aware of it
right and who cares about those people
because anyone who watched the game i
already had thought the giants put a
respectable performance out there
because they hung a lot tougher than
people were giving them credit for i
mean
you know the first half it's 14 14 going
almost into half the patriots scored
before half but that game felt like the
giants had something going where they
were gonna they were gonna hang around
it was a seven point game going into the
fourth quarter so the giants did the
respectable thing and who cares about
whatever people flip their you know the
newspaper and didn't watch the game so
to to make that decision for those
people
like you said very shallow very i i just
hate it i hate the message it sends can
we talk also mike the fact that daniel
jones who
i think has shown that he can play at
this level and the excitement around him
is real
but the same thing that happened at duke
is now showing up here in the nfl and
that's turnovers he's had nine turnovers
in uh in in his all in his uh
appearances he's had eight in his four
starts he's had six interceptions
you can't win well actually i should say
you can win with turnovers because the
giants did it with eli for many years
but
turning the ball over at the rate he is
right now is not a great omen for what's
going forward because this was the thing
something that plagued him all along and
it seems like it hasn't been fixed
and that's the reality when you go from
the college level to the nfl level the
windows get tighter if you have turnover
issues especially interceptions at the
college level you're most likely going
to have more at the pro level one guy
that's flipped that around has been
desean watson because as the windows get
tighter he's gotten more accurate in the
nfl but most guys if you've got issues
turning the ball over
at north carolina you're going to have a
hell of a lot more problem when you're
the quarterback of the new york giants
so i agree with you there even though he
has passed the eyeball test you can't
give short fields you can't give pick
sixes or you know what whatever may
contribute to the other team getting the
ball and turning it into points and
that's helped the patriots they've been
so opportunistic all year that 35 to 14
looks like their offense is fine and
their offense is anything but fine they
had to go with one personnel grouping
for a lot of the second half because of
injuries they don't have rob gronkowski
they don't have antonio brown they don't
have ben watson and you can tell that
tom brady's getting a little frustrated
with all this big cat
yeah he's getting frustrated and
rightfully so because
add on all of what you just said in
terms of the lack of weapons and their
offensive line has not looked you know
very good i know they've had some
injuries but even even running the ball
which the patriots have kind of morphed
into this team the last couple of years
and of course bill belichick at any
point he can morph into a different team
that's that's the genius of bill
belichick that one week he can pass she
pass all over you and shred you with the
passing game the next week he can play
bully ball but i think the as tom brady
gets older and maybe the uh and the
dynamic kind of shifts here where the
defense has been very very good and the
offense needs to play a little more of a
ball control game they weren't even able
to run the ball probably the way that
bill belichick wanted to it was still
effective it was right around four yards
of carry for sony michelle but still the
patriots offense
it doesn't have that rhythm that we can
just go out there roll it out there and
cut you up left and right uh you know 10
11 12 play drives and they were playing
a very bad and undermanned giants
defense last night i know the conditions
were bad but the patriots have played a
lot of
really bad teams what's gonna happen
when they start playing some of the good
teams on their schedule and are those
games going to be closer because the
offense has not found a way to bring it
all together i also want to say right
here mike thank you to tom brady because
it looks like the patriots are going to
obviously be in the playoffs obviously
have a fantastic record but tom brady's
playing right on that level where he
gives
idiots like us enough to talk about the
next morning and say is tom brady
getting too old is this the end for tom
brady he's giving the sports media world
enough to doubt him which you should
never do
but he thank you to him he's being a
gentleman and a scholar in that
yeah and look i understand the sarcasm
there but i don't think he is giving us
ammunition to doubt him we can doubt the
pieces around him but i don't think we
can doubt him but he has his doubts you
mentioned the schedule is going to get
tougher inevitably they play the jets
next week but then they've got cleveland
they've got baltimore they have the bye
week after that it's the eagles it's the
cowboys it's the texans it's the chiefs
they are gonna have to score more points
let's watch and listen to tom brady's
reaction last night when he was asked
after the game about the performance of
the offense
what's your assessment of where you guys
are as an offense right now do you think
it's been good enough
uh
we'll see we're 6-0 so
try to get 7-0
so thank you guys appreciate it
i love that move by brady choosing his
words very carefully running them all
through the filter with the double shrug
the pause and ultimately the smile we'll
see
i'm sure he wanted to say a lot more
than that and he has recently bristled a
little bit about the offense big
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports